>> THEY FORCED HER TO FORCE
AGAINST A BIOLOGICAL MAIL SEEING
THAT ON YOUR SCREEN NOW.
>> Tucker: SHE TIED DESPITE
THE OBVIOUS DISADVANTAGE.
SHE SAID THE NCAA IS BADLY
HANDLED EVERY ASPECT OF THIS
COMPETITION AND BEEN TRYING FOR
MONTHS TO GET COLOR SWIMMER ON
THE SHOW IT'S WHAT WOULD THEY
THINK IS HAPPENING NONE OF
ACCEPTED EXCEPT FOR ALLY WERE
GRATEFUL FOR THAT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
I'LL JUST LET YOU TALK TELL US
WHAT YOU THINK OF YOUR
EXPERIENCE AT THIS EVENT?
>> HIGH TUCKER THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR HAVING ME AND FORGIVE ME
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK FOR
MYSELF AND SO MANY OTHER WOMEN
ATHLETES OUT THERE WHO AREN'T AS
FORTUNATE AS ME ENOUGH TO HAVE
BEEN TOLD THAT THERE NOT A LOT
OF TALK ABOUT IT SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THAT.
LIKE YOU SAID ME AND LEAH JUST
RECENTLY TIED AT THE NCAA
CHAMPIONSHIPS AND HONESTLY I
THINK THE NCAA HANDLED
EVERYTHING EXTERNALLY POORLY,
STARTING FROM ONE WE FINISH AND
I WENT BEHIND THE PODIUM TO
COLLECT MY FIFTH PLACE TROPHY,
PLAINLY TOLD ME THAT LEAH WOULD
HOLD THE FIFTH PLACE TROPHY AND
THEN I COULD POST WITH THE SIX
PLACE TROPHY FOR PHOTOS AND
WOULD BE MAILED THE FIFTH PLACE
TROPHY IN THE MAIL.
>> Tucker: NOT ONLY ARE THEY
ALLOWING BIOLOGICAL MAIL TO
COMPETE IN THE WOMEN'S
COMPETITION THEY ARE PROMOTING
THAT MAIL OVER BIOLOGICAL
FEMALES WHO ARE COMPETING,
THAT'S WHEN I'M READING FROM
WHAT YOU SAID.
>> RIGHT, WHY CAN A QUESTION
THAT I ASKED HIM IF THERE'S A
REASON WHY GIVING THE OTHER
TROPHY AND IS EXPLAINED TO ME
THAT WERE GIVING IN
CHRONOLOGICAL ORDER I QUESTION
HIM AGAIN YOU KNOW WHAT IS THAT
MEAN?
WE TIED ONE TO CHRONOLOGICAL
ABOUT?
[LAUGHS]
HE BLATANTLY SAID THEY WERE JUST
GIVE THE TROPHY TO LEAH, WE
EXPECT AND REMARK YOUR SWIM BUT
LEAH GETS A HOLD THE TROPHY.
>> Tucker: AND OTHER QUESTIONS
DON'T ASK QUESTIONS?
>> I WISH HE WAS SHOCKED BECAUSE
ALL THE OTHER SWIMMERS WHO WERE
STANDING BY LISTENING TO THIS
ARE ALSO SHOCKED AND STANDING
RIGHT NEXT TO LEAH AND SHE HEARD
IT ALL SO IS KIND OF JUST REALLY
BAFFLING THAT THIS COULD HAPPEN
AND I KNOW THE NCAA WASN'T
PREPARED FOR SITUATION LIKE
THIS.
WHICH JUST TELLS ME THAT ONE OF
HER FACE WITH IT THEY PROTECTED
SUCH A SMALL MINORITY IN TURN
THEIR BACK ON WHAT THE
ORGANIZATION AND TITLE IX REALLY
STANDS FOR.
>> Tucker: THEY JUST
ILLUMINATED WHAT IT STANDS FOR.
IT SEEMS TO A NONSWIMMER WHO
KNOWS THAT SWIMMING REQUIRES A
LOT OF TORTURE, SOMETHING HARDER
THAN SWIM PRACTICE.
AS YOU KNOW, THIS SEEMS LIKE
CHEATING TO ALLOW SOMEONE WITH A
BIOLOGICAL ADVANTAGE TO COMPETE.
>> EXACTLY, I THINK THAT THERE
IS A DEFINITE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
YOUR, AND YOUR GENDER IDENTITY
AND I THINK THAT IT'S JUST BEEN
TOTALLY MISCONSTRUED AND LOST IN
THE PAST COUPLE OF YEARS OR SO.
IT'S FINALLY GONE TO THE POINT
WHERE IT'S BEING SHOWN AND IS
COMPLETELY VIOLATING WOMEN AND
WOMEN'S RIGHTS ESPECIALLY IN
SPORTS.
>> Tucker: YOU SET A MINUTE
AGO THAT YOU'RE SPEAKING TONIGHT
ON BEHALF OF A LOT OF OTHER
FEMALE SWIMMERS WHO'VE BEEN TOLD
NOT TO SAY WORDS JUST TO BE
QUIET AND BE ELIMINATED.
WHAT DO THEY THINK IF YOU COULD
SPEAK FOR THEM?
>> RIGHT, I KNOW JUST TALKING TO
TONS, AND TONS OF NCAA SWIMMERS
THAT THEIR ATHLETIC DIRECTORS
THEIR MEDIA PEOPLE AND THEIR
COACHES OR OTHER OUTSIDE
INFLUENCE HAVE TOLD THEM DON'T
SAY ANYTHING, JUST AVOID THE
SITUATION, SAY FACE A LITTLE BIT
I'M JUST FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO
DRIVE SUCH AN AMAZING SUPPORT
SYSTEM AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
KENTUCKY, WHETHER THAT BE FROM
THE ATHLETIC DIRECTOR ALL THE
WAY DOWN MY HEAD COACH.
JUST BEGIN FOR THEM WHICH IS
TOTALLY WRONG.
I KNOW I CAN'T SPEAK FOR
EVERYONE BUT I'M ALMOST CERTAIN
THAT I'M SPEAKING FOR LARGE
MAJORITY OF FEMALE ATHLETES AND
THIS IS JUST NOT OKAY.
AND IT'S NOT FAIR.
WERE DEALING WITH SOMETHING
THAT'S COMPLETELY OUT OF OUR
CONTROL WHEN RACING, BIOLOGICAL
MALES WHETHER THEY HAVE
DIFFERENT LUNG CAPACITY, THEIR
HEIGHT OBVIOUSLY.
TESTOSTERONE LEVELS WHETHER
TESTOSTERONE BLOCKERS ARE NOT.
IT DOESN'T SUPPRESS GOING
THROUGH PUBERTY IS A MALE.
ESPECIALLY THE ONE IN QUESTION
SWAM FOR YEARS AS A MALE ON NEW
PEN.
IT'S COMPLETELY UNFAIR AND IT'S
A MATTER EQUITY REALLY.
>> Tucker: YEP, WHAT WERE
SEEING TO
SAY THAT AND IT IS IN YOUR BRIEF
ARE DOING IT AND WE APPRECIA